ce refuge de Winnipeg offre un abri à
tous ceux qui souhaitent se réchauffer
ou trouver de quoi manger c'est aussi
l'endroit où Jérémy skibiki aurait
rencontré de nombreuses femmes
autochtones avec l'idée de les ramener
chez lui il est accusé des meurtres au
premier degré de Morgane Harris mars
Rebecca comptoir et d'une femme
autochtone inconnue surnommée Buffalo
women et il appelait des non coupable
trois d'entre elles vivaient dans les
tinérances
qui s'est passé raconte cet homme à qui
nous avons accordé l'anonymat il craint
que sa famille découvre qu'il vit dans
l'itinérance
avait pourtant son propre appartement au
moins 30 femmes auraient résidées avec
lui sur différentes périodes selon ses
amis vivant dans le même immeuble qui
nous avons accordé l'anonymat en raison
de crainte de représailles
les organismes qui luttent contre les
tinérance sont en deuil pour la
directrice générale du refuge salon
Michel au centre-ville de Winnipeg c'est
l'occasion de prendre un pas de recul et
de trouver des solutions pour améliorer
la sécurité des femmes autochtones
que Jérémy skibiki a rencontré son
ex-femme l'année dernière elle a obtenu
une ordonnance de protection contre lui
puisqu'elle était victime de violence
conjugales et craignait pour sa vie mais
pourquoi tant de femmes auraient décidé
de suivre Jérémy skillik
dans la rue le sentiment de sécurité
peut être attirant et quand on a plus
rien on est prêt à tout accepter la au
coeur de cette affaire il y a surtout le
désespoir ici Anne-Charlotte Carignan
Radio-Canada win